(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
- Y'all know how this goes.
♪ Baby, I hear the blues a-calling ♪
♪ Tossed salads and scrambled eggs ♪
♪ And maybe I seem a bit confused ♪
♪ Yeah maybe, but I got you pegged ♪
♪ But I don't know what to do ♪
♪ With those tossed salads
and scrambled eggs ♪
♪ Life's calling again, hey ♪
- Give it up for the band, y'all.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
♪ Bi, ba, bi, di, doo, pa, pa, ra ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ All right ♪
♪ Hey baby, I hear the blues a-calling ♪
♪ Tossed salads and scrambled eggs ♪
♪ And maybe I seem a bit confused ♪
♪ Yeah maybe, but I got you pegged ♪
♪ I don't know ♪
♪ But I don't know what to do ♪
♪ With those tossed salads
and scrambled eggs ♪
♪ Life's calling again ♪
♪ Scrambled eggs all over my face ♪
♪ What is a boy to do ♪
- I love you, give it up.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Thank you for jamming out with me.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Welcome to "The Kelly
Clarkson Show", everybody.
Give it up for the band.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(Kelly exclaiming)
And a big hand to Mr. Kelsey Grammer.
This is like a dream
come true for me, y'all.
That was the theme song from
his new series, "Frasier",
which is a reboot of literally, possibly,
I mean, that's a top two
show for me of all time.
"Frasier" is like one of my favorite,
you have no idea.
- Thank you.
- I'm freaking out right now.
That's a reboot of "Frasier",
you can watch a new one, I'm so excited.